hello everyone my name is emily and this
is some sub a channel all about survival
in the digital jungle we've become more
dependent on computers and smartphones
than maybe we thought
try to count how many telephone numbers
can you remember by heart
most probably you know your own
telephone number maybe even your home
phone number if you have one
and that's all
at the beginning of the 2000s each of us
remember dozens of telephone numbers the
numbers of our friends our parents and
work colleagues but smartphones totally
remove the need to remember strings of
unrelated digits
we've also become more vulnerable
imagine that you're strolling around the
centre of rome admiring the grandeur of
the coliseum and all of a sudden a thief
grabs your bag or rucksack and makes off
with it
you've lost your phone and your wallet
what do you do next
are you able to explain what happened
without the help of google translate
can you find the road back to your hotel
without sat nav can you even get in
touch with any of your friends or family
to tell them what happened
we really don't notice how computers
have become such an integral part of our
lives
every year we shift more and more
routine tasks over to them they're
better than us at processing huge
amounts of data they work without rest
or lunch breaks and they never make
mistakes
well
almost never and this almost is not
without consequences sometimes it can
turn into losses of money reputation or
even life today we'll discuss whether or
not we should trust our digital
assistants
[Music]
look at this sweet little elderly woman
her real name is leslie shook but
thousands of americans whose lives she
saved called her bitching betty
now this might sound rude to you but
this nickname was invented by people who
by the nature of their activities their
work often risk their lives every day
i'm talking about the pilots of the
american f-18 super hornet fighters
during takeoff and landing they have to
simultaneously monitor several dozen
parameters altitude speed course flat
position and so on
this is an incredible load even for
highly trained pilots
in such conditions such as bad weather
with strong winds or damage to the
aircraft the probability of errors
increases significantly
to alert the pilots to dangerous changes
in these flight parameters boeing
engineers have created a system of voice
prompts
this is called the cockpit warning
system
and the voice of this system
leslie any pilot having heard her short
demanding orders won't hesitate to carry
them out light controls flight controls
bingo bingo now it sounds a lot like a
navigator in a car doesn't it but you
definitely shouldn't blindly follow the
navigator instructions
otherwise you might find yourself
cruising along the bottom of a lake as
happened to a resident of the canadian
city of kitchener a 23 year old woman
was returning home late at night in
thick fog with roadsides barely visible
so the girl was relying almost totally
on the navigator's commands rather than
by road signs
and after another turn the car was in
the water
the navigator had laid out a route right
across the bottom of lake ontario
fortunately the girl managed to get out
of the sinking car and reach the shore
but how did this happen most likely
there was once a ferry crossing in this
place which was recorded by the map in
the navigator and therefore the program
boldly plotted a route through it the
girl was very tired this story took
place around midnight in poor visibility
so she simply didn't notice that instead
of driving along the road she'd found
herself on a boat ramp but her biggest
mistake here was trusting the electronic
assistant make all right maybe it's a
shortcut dwight it said go to the right
it can't mean that there's a leg there
knows where it is
the machine
stop yelling at me
there's no room here
car navigators are a great example of an
unreliable advisor
in terms of communication they're
similar to the computer in the f-18
fighter
they also give clear and simple commands
but the key difference is in the amount
of information they operate on
the aircraft's computer receives
information from several hundred sensors
enabling it to clearly determine its
position in space its speed and flight
parameters
it has the radar data of the fighter
itself as well as other aircraft at its
disposal
to determine the coordinates of the
plane it uses the military protocol of
working with gps additional signals from
ground stations and in case of satellite
failure it continuously calculates the
position of the aircraft using an
inertial system
during landing even more external data
is used the coarse glide system of an
airfield or an aircraft carrier
radio beacons and so on now by comparing
all of this data the computer can detect
failures in the operation of individual
sensors and this won't affect the
accuracy of its orders by contrast the
navigator in the car is deaf and blind
it lives in the past
the route is based on a pre-compiled and
uploaded map
any changes are delayed especially if
we're talking about built-in navigators
which most often have to be updated at
service centers the only thing the
navigator knows about the real world is
gps coordinates but even these aren't so
straightforward
in civilian systems this channel is not
protected
therefore the resulting coordinates can
easily be distorted or substituted
this is called gps spoofing
for example regular cyber engineers
claim that thanks to such an attack they
actually managed to force a tesla car
off the road the lack of data about the
outside world is the main obstacle to
the emergence of fully fledged
autopilots for ordinary cars
now i'm impressed by the success of
tesla they almost managed to create a
system that can analyze the situation in
real time
but unfortunately this very word real
almost spoils everything
in real life there are too many
chaotically changing parameters on the
road so sometimes a computer
turns into a blind kernel driving a
ferrari
[Music]
[Applause]
don't blame me charlie i can't see so
autopilots took root in aviation where
all systems are duplicated two or three
times where any system passes dozens of
tests and during real flight uses the
most complex ground infrastructure
autopilot also performs well in
conditions where the number of external
factors is reduced to a minimum for
example on the railways or in the subway
and yet in our cars we continue to trust
computers that operate with wholly
insufficient amounts of data so
if you're not a supersonic fighter pilot
never take the instructions of your
navigator or computer as an order now
this is just my recommendation you can
make your own mind up about this now
unfortunately insufficient data is far
from the only problem
even if the computer receives complete
and reliable information this doesn't
mean that new errors won't occur
[Music]
and for those of you who love our videos
about money laundering and the fight
against this type of fraud there is
important news our second channel some
sub for experts has published an
interview with one of these aml stars
iannos ashiotis now janus is a grant
daunting professional whose expertise is
landing global financial businesses on
cyprus regulatory soil our host and
chief legal officer tony talked to him
about the future of crypto in the eu and
also starting a fully legitimate
cryptocurrency exchange in europe
there's a lot of requirements but people
that are in the crypto industry
are not going to find these things
to be extreme sounds interesting it is
and i hope you enjoy
[Music]
on our channel bradley lucas and i have
repeatedly told you that your phone is a
real snitch
a mobile phone even a simple push button
nokia constantly exchanges information
with base stations
recording this exchange helps the police
to establish where your phone was at the
time of a crime or conversely to
identify users who were near a certain
place police in many countries use
similar methods but they don't always
work correctly in 2019 a scandal broke
out in denmark over a system of
automated identification of suspects in
crimes
two serious errors were found at once in
the algorithm of the data processing
module of mobile operators the first of
them was due to the fact that the system
discarded some of the data which
sometimes significantly distorted the
coordinates of specific mobile phone
users therefore innocent people could
suddenly find themselves at the scene of
a crime the second error caused the
distortion of data on the movement of
users between towers in some places
swapping the location of criminals and
law-abiding citizens
just two inaccuracies in working with
the data led to the revision of 10 700
criminal cases in which the results of
the system were used the result of the
investigation dealt a huge blow to the
image of the entire danish law
enforcement system
the reputation of telecom companies also
suffered in this situation only the
lawyers were satisfied they had more
arguments with which to defend their
clients so far in fact they've already
managed to secure the release of 32
convicts whose charges were based on the
use of phone geolocation data can you
imagine what it's like to spend several
years of your life in prison just
because someone made a small mistake in
a computer program but sometimes errors
in the code are not just errors but
malicious intent
have you ever heard of nationalist
computers
unlikely unless you're dutch
the fact is that the social services of
this wonderful country use computers to
process information about the payment of
child care benefits
the system helped employees of social
services process these applications for
these payments assess the real wealth of
families and analyze the use of these
benefits however it turned out that
officials and programmers made the
system a little biased for example
if one of the parents was not a dutch
citizen or had dual citizenship he was
automatically assigned the status of an
unreliable person such people
automatically became suspected of fraud
and even minor formal errors when
filling out questionnaires and forms
were considered to be deliberate
criminal actions of course all this
should have been easy to spot by people
working in social services but
unfortunately they too often relied on
the opinion of the computer system
without understanding the reasons they
approved of the computer's verdict
computer 30th all this turned into a big
scandal which in 2021 led to the
resignation of the entire cabinet of
ministers of mark rutter the dutch
government now has to pay a fine of 2.75
million euros and compensation to the
victims at an average of 30 000 euros
per family as far as i know this fine
was the first payout for automated
discrimination of citizens however
similar processes are now developing in
other countries that are always making
mistakes
in australia errors were found in the
algorithm that made decisions on the
payment of government subsidies and in
austria discriminatory algorithms were
found in the employment service system
it doesn't like women or the elderly
often underestimating their chances of
finding a job therefore if you work in
the social sphere or you're engaged in
the investigation of crimes never and
i'll repeat never trust computer systems
any decision that affects the fate of
other people should only be made by a
person as consciously and impartially as
possible and if you're responsible for
developing such systems
don't forget that even a small mistake
can genuinely ruin the lives of other
people my logic is undeniable yes vicky
undeniable so as you can see sometimes
computers take on our weaknesses and
prejudices
perhaps in the future artificial
intelligence systems based on
self-learning neural networks will cope
with this problem bradley's already
talked a little bit about them in the
video ai against money laundering so if
you want to know how a computer learns
to play chess or go by itself you should
head over and give it a watch
[Music]
500 years before our time the greek poet
theogonist of megara wrote that no
mortal is free from mistakes now
unfortunately this statement is also
true for computers do you want me to
show you an instance where you can count
better than your computer try to add up
one tenth and two tenths in your mind so
i'm sure you immediately said that the
answer is three tenths
this is elementary maths for a human but
extremely difficult for a computer
most programming languages operate with
numbers according to the ieee 754
standard
in it numbers are represented by powers
of two
therefore one-tenth turns into such a
monster
you see for a computer this fraction
turned out to be slightly more than the
true value
the same happens with other fractions
two tenths will become a little more and
three tenths a little less than their
real values
therefore adding one tenth and two
tenths together the computer will
what the hell don't believe it well type
this number into your browser and
add.com
you will then be taken to a site where
examples of programs that calculate
these expressions in different
programming languages are collected
so you can check for yourself
now this contradicts both sound logic
and our own experiences
after all in spreadsheets or calculators
a different correct result is obtained
so why is this happening now programmers
have allowed for rounding the results
for such calculations
a long tail of small values is discarded
from such fractions the fraction is
rounded up or down and all calculations
are performed according to this value
but sometimes this rounding doesn't
quite work as planned and this can cause
some truly fatal errors
for example accumulated rounding errors
led to the death of 28
and the injury of 96 american soldiers
now let me tell you the story
on the evening of february 25th in 1991
during the last days of operation desert
storm iraqi forces launched a missile
attack on a barracks in saudi arabia
american soldiers considered themselves
safe they were already covered by one of
the best air defense systems the mim-104
patriot it was guaranteed to intercept
any missiles that saddam hussein had
only this time patriot missed
due to rounding errors the system was
unable to shoot down the old scud
ballistic missile
the error in the program was spotted
almost two weeks before the tragedy
israeli experts had noticed that after
eight hours of continuous operation the
system began to miss 20 of targets on
february 16th the software fix was ready
but it was delivered to the base in
saudi arabia only on february 26 the day
after the tragedy
the most shocking thing about this story
is the losses could have been avoided
even without updating the program
on february 21st four days before the
missile strike the command issued an
order prohibiting the long continuous
use of the system
it's just that the concept of long in
this instance wasn't defined
if the order had contained clear
instructions about the need to restart
the guidance computer every eight hours
then perhaps the tragedy wouldn't have
happened
unfortunately it wasn't long before the
next catastrophe due to the
peculiarities of computerized
calculations took place
in 1996 the european space agency burned
7 billion into dust
in 37 seconds
the first launch of the ariane 5 heavy
lift rocket turned into the most
expensive fireworks display in the
history of mankind due to a similar
software error
two smaller variables used to track
speed data
this module was used on the previous
generation of rockets but these ariana 4
parameters were significantly lower than
that on ariana 5. in half a minute the
speed value went beyond the capabilities
of the variable and the program began to
interpret them as negative
a small mistake by one programmer
obliterated 10 years of hard work by the
entire european space agency
[Music]
[Music]
we trust computers too much according to
a study conducted at mit tesla owners
rely too much on autopilot capabilities
in 22 of cases they take their eyes off
the road for more than two seconds now
at a speed of a hundred kilometers per
hour this is enough time for a car to
cross a football field so why do we
blindly trust in perfect computer
systems professor timothy hoff from new
york has been dealing with automation
problems in medical institutions for a
long time
for example he interviewed more than 75
colleagues who actively use a computer
during patient appointments
hoff observed that doctors have become
less understanding of their patients
they concentrate more on filling out
electronic forms and make less decisions
about diagnosis and upcoming treatments
on their own
we share responsibility with computer
systems too easily
this was clearly demonstrated by the
investigations into danish and dutch
social workers but by its very nature
the brain tends to want to economize its
efforts
we're always looking for ways to
simplify tasks and if an automated
system can offer a solution that is
suitable we're all too happy to take it
a mechanism that scientists call
automation bias has come into action
we subconsciously trust machines more
than ourselves or other people we're
used to making mistakes we're used to
deception but we don't expect the same
behavior from an inanimate object
therefore we trust the strange
instructions of the satnav and agree
with the recommendations of a supposedly
expert system this is our main mistake
computers smartphones crm and erp
systems are very complex and intelligent
but still at all
and
furthermore they're made by human beings
with a tendency to make mistakes
according to probability theory
the probability of errors does not add
up but multiplies so that's why i'm not
ready to put my trust in computers just
yet
but what about you
share your thoughts about it in the
comments down below
so all that's left is for me to say
goodbye to you
my name's emily
this has been some sub and i'll be
waiting for you on the next expedition
into the digital jungle
[Music]